- Good morning believe nation
my name is Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your
journey today's message
is discomfort is your friend.
Over to you Joe Rogan.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Our bodies for whatever reason
most people their associations
are to avoid anything that's uncomfortable
but it's so illogical
because when you look at comfort
and you look at success and progress
and the eventual feelings
of accomplishment
and of getting past certain hurtles
in terms of how you feel about life.
A lot of those are
connected to discomfort.
Discomfort is your friend.
It really is.
Discomfort and not being happy and content
with certain situations in life
or certain feelings in life,
there are massive motivators
and they're amazing at facilitating change
and yet our instinct is to avoid those
and just sit on the couch
and watch some reality show
about dudes who make moonshine
with our jaw open like (gurgles)
it's bizarre.
- You can measure your growth in life
as a human being by how much discomfort
you're regularly experiencing.
There's that old expression that you need
to scare yourself everyday.
Right we hear it in songs.
We hear it in radio.
We hear it on TV.
We read it in books.
You got to do something
that scares you every day
and it's great advice.
It's amazing advice.
We just don't do it.
Do you do something that
scares you everyday?
When was the last time you did something
that actually scares you?
When you aren't doing
things that scare you
that's when you see insane growth.
That's when you see yourself developing,
your business developing
and it may not happen right away
but through that process
of scaring yourself
and getting uncomfortable,
that's when you start
seeing amazing things happen
and you feel great.
You feel scared but you also feel great
because we love to grow
'cause as humans we want to grow.
We want to get better.
We want to learn.
We want to develop ourselves
and so what I would encourage you to do is
try to develop the habit
of you can either consciously say
I'm tryin' to do somethin'
to scare myself everyday.
Right?
Which can be a good practice
but also can be reactive
in that when you have an idea
or somebody asks you to do something
and you get those nerves.
Right?
You get those nerves that scare you.
I don't want to do that I might fail.
To recognize that and then
to build and grow from that.
To start building that muscle of fear
and breaking through it.
I think it's really important.
I think most of what
we do is subconscious.
I think most of the actions
you take will be subconscious.
You will just naturally play smaller
without even thinking about it.
You'll rationalize the fear.
Right?
You'll rationalize the discomfort.
You really want to start a YouTube channel
and the real reason is you're afraid
to get in front of the camera.
You're afraid of people's judgment of you
but instead of recognizing that
you'll say oh but I don't have the money,
just to get a camera.
I don't have the time.
I have a really busy life
and you know I got to get the gear
and the lights, the microphone
and I don't know even know if I need
to go to school for this.
All the irrationalize the reason
but deep down it's just fear.
You're just afraid.
So the first step is just understanding
that it's fear.
That you're really just
afraid of doing this thing
and then when you understand that,
practice developing the
courage to go and do it.
Whenever I feel myself
being a little bit afraid,
worried about other people's expectations,
then I know I have to go up and do it.
So a couple examples,
I went to Paris not that long ago
and was speaking on stage
at a key note speech
to close out a conference.
There's about 2000 people in the room
and I've done tons of
these speeches right?
I've done a lot of speeches
and every time I go I want to try
and do something new.
Something different.
Not just for the audience,
'cause a lot of the audience
hadn't seen me before.
For myself.
I don't want to get up on stage
and just do the same speech
that I've always done.
Every time I go I want to do
something different for myself
and so this time I went up
and I didn't use any slides.
I had one slide the entire presentation.
Usually I had slides
that would have pictures,
I'd follow it along the
story of what I was saying.
I don't read from slides
I've never done that.
Well maybe probably when I
started a bit from slides
but this time I was like you know what
I have a 20 minute presentation.
I'm going to get on the stage.
I'm just going to go.
And the initial fears that come back
like what if I forget
what I'm going to say?
What if I lose track?
Because the pictures at
least kept me on track
and what if I miss a point?
You know.
I shouldn't do it you know,
I've been paid to come here
and I need to make sure I'm
providing a lot of value
and that's maybe not the smartest idea.
All of these fears come in.
Like no I'm going to do it.
I got to do it.
I need to push myself for me
and I was so nervous
there was a guy speaking before me
I just couldn't wait for him to finish
'cause all the way
through his presentation,
I'm thinking okay what am I going to say?
I got to say this, I got to say this.
Fears, fears, fears, fears.
They announce my name
instead of walkin' around the stage
like everybody else does
I just jumped onto the stage.
I was in the front row.
Evan Carmichael.
I jumped on the stage and the MC
had to come and shake my hand upfront
instead of around the side.
I think it's important.
I think it's important for yourself.
That you do the things that
make you feel uncomfortable.
I told this story before on my channel.
Even making videos here
I'm worried about people walking behind me
and doin' it in a public setting instead
of closing the doors
or doing somewhere else
or wearing different colored socks
because my son did it
and then i was worried
that people would judge
me if I tried to do it
because I was worried about the judgment.
I had to go out and do it.
Or listening to music when
I'm walkin' in the street
and dancing and then when I get to close
to a busy intersection.
Dancing smaller.
See that you catch it.
See you'll dance smaller just naturally.
You'll play smaller naturally.
But if you can catch it
that's when you can say
no I'm not impacting these people.
I'm not tryin' to make
their life worse right?
My dancing,
my doing whatever I
want to do in the street
doesn't impact them.
If anything it's giving them
something different to look at.
It's bringing a little more joy.
They might tell their co-worker
they saw this crazy guy
on the street dancing.
Maybe they go back to their office
and dance a little bit more.
Maybe what I'm doing is
actually inspiring them.
But an actual baseball
so you can catch it.
That's when you got to take the action.
There's that great
expression of doing something
everyday that scares you
but we don't actually do it.
So I would encourage you
so when you feel that discomfort
try to recognize it.
Try to see it as this
is muscle building time
and go out and do it.
So the question today is I'm curious
what was the last thing
you did that scared you?
Leave it down in the comments below
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Priest Willis.
Priest thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support
and hope you enjoyed my book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- If I had to rewind the clock 10 years
I would've insisted by people
that are close to me,
please push me into very unsafe projects.
At least every other one.
I think it's professionally responsible
to not continue to remake the same role
over and over again.
What's tonight?
Turkey TV dinner, turkey TV dinner.
[Interviewer] so it looks like you always
go out of your comfort zone right?
Coming onto an island that
was completely deserted,
no fresh water you didn't
even have the money to buy it
and now you're sleeping
on a tent on the beach
trying to figure out how
to get fresh water here.
You do that often.
You did it with the airline?
- I was just somebody that experienced
the bad experience of
traveling on airlines.
I was actually trying to get to the BVI,
the British Virgin Islands
one day from Puerto Rico
and the same lovely
lady was waiting for me
and I'd been away for three weeks
and American Airlines bumped the flight
and so I went to the back of the airport
I hired a plane.
I had a black board.
I wrote Virgin Airlines
one way $29 to BVI.
Went around all the
people who had been bumped
and I filled my first plane.
And that got me thinking that airlines
do bump people they don't care
about you or me particularly
in the air so then rang up Boeing
and said do you have any second N747's--
- No kidding I mean it was literally
that you just sat in the airport
and said I'm starting an airline right now
because I'm frustrated.
- Exactly.
And I think most of the
best entrepreneurial ideas
come out of frustration I think.
If you're frustrated about something,
the best way of sorting it out
is get out and do it.
And you've got yourself a business.
- Starting with Lincoln
Lawyer was a time when I said
I wanted to recalibrate my relationship
with my career.
I remember saying that.
I remember thinking my career,
I'm enjoying it.
I love what it's given me.
I like goin' to work.
I like the things I've been doin'.
But everything I started reading
I felt like oh,
it's another version
of something I've done
or I feel like I could do it next week
and I remember going well wait a minute
before you get mad at thinking
you could do something next week,
that's a valid feeling.
Don't just say no to something
'cause you can feel like
you can naturally do it
but then I said okay fair I'll shake
with you on that McConaughey but...
(audience laughs)
Let me find something that I don't know
how what to do with that next week
or the week after.
Anytime something that I really like
but I'm goin oh I'm not sure.
That scares me that shakes my floor
and I was fortunate
enough to that schedule F.
Check I got in the Angels in the Outfield.
Didn't know that my rent was paid.
I was fortunate enough that
all my kids were going to eat.
I was just shepherding my
first son into the world.
So I had that to take care of my time.
I said it's a great time
to go in the shadows
and be a father and sit back
and see if something turns
you on from the inside
or if something finds you
if you're the target.
We're okay rent's paid.
Kids are going to eat.
We can take some time off.
I in know way was
thinking about oh I'm done
but I didn't know how long the dry spell
was going to go so I said
no to some of the things
that were similar to what
I had been doing before
and it took awhile I had
to sit down with my agent
and say hey I'm really going to do this
and I need your help with
my commitment to this
because after eight months
if the same thing comes in
with a big 10 million dollar
paycheck it starts to
read better and funnier.
(audience laughs)
I promise you.
I mean the same words.
All the sudden I think this thing's great.
(audience laughs)
I think I can find an angle.
No I can make it a
different experience for me.
So I said I'm going to need your help
bunkering down there and
saying no to some things
and so I'm going to need
you to be a gate keeper
one to keep from getting to me,
two let's be real clear I'm lookin'
for some different things to do.
He holed up he handled that.
My wife we said we don't know
how long it's going to be dry
then after they quit sending those,
then it did get dry.
Then nothing came for about year.
There's nothing.
I didn't have any sleepless nights
or oh my gosh.
I was like no I'll find something.
I'll write.
I was writing a lot.
I was turning myself on creatively
and as I said I had my first
son to shepherd into the world.
And then the funny thing happened.
The beautiful thing happened
that I somehow I was the target,
drew the arrow and I think my opinion is
I became a new good
idea by removing myself.
I became William Frincken calls,
Steven Soderberg calls for the first time.
Somehow in that two years
I became fresh new idea
that I don't think I was
two, three years prior.
How that works I'm not sure because
I didn't send a memo out.
(audience laughs)